hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen whether you're back to
work school or you're just coming to
terms with the fact that skipping out of
work at 2:00 p.m. on a Friday afternoon
for patio drinks is becoming
unacceptable the change in season means
that life is the best get a little bit
heavier
you've got deadlines PTA meetings and
mountains of housework that you've
neglected for the past three months the
last thing you want to have to worry
about is a snack so that's why I came up
with these three and naturally
gluten-free after work or school snacks
packed with lots of peanut a good nuts
first up my peanut butter cherry energy
balls into a food processor I add one
cup of dry roasted lightly seasoned
peanuts one and a quarter cups of
roughly chopped dates a quarter cup of
dried cherries 1/4 cup of natural peanut
butter two teaspoons of ground flax seed
and half a cup of freeze dried cherries
process until smooth and sticky then
roll into balls
a lot of people wrongly assume that
peanuts aren't very good for them
probably because they're just so damn
irresistible but I think those people
are nuts peanuts are loaded with the
hunger crushing combination of protein
fiber and heart healthy monounsaturated
fats plus just check out this long list
of nutrients you get in between any
packed snack and while they may fall
potato chips as the second most popular
snack
they are deathly up there in the most
nutritious I like using unsalted peanuts
and natural peanut butter which is lower
and sodium and has no added sugar next
up my peanut butter
apricot granola bars I add half a cup of
peanuts and two cups of apricots to the
food processor and pulse until they
break up into small pieces then I add 2
cups of gluten-free rolled oats 2
tablespoons of ground flaxseed 1 cup of
natural peanut butter half a cup of
honey
and 1 teaspoon of vanilla extract and
process until smooth and stick roughly
chop that remaining quarter cup of
peanuts and add it to the mixture along
with 2 cups of brown rice cereal then
online
a 13 by 8 inch rectangular pan with wax
or parchment paper and press the mixture
into the bottom of the pan refrigerate
until solid and then cut it in too far
and finally my peanut butter banana and
chocolate smoothie I add 1 tbsp of
natural peanut butter one large frozen
ripe banana 1 TSP of Graham flax 2
teaspoons unsweetened cocoa powder 1/2 a
cup of skim milk and a half a cup of
plain Greek yogurt 2 a blender and puree
until smooth pour it into a large glass
and enjoy
so there you have it three healthy after
work is food snacks packed with the
flavor your kids love and the energy
boosting benefits you are after - thank
you so much for watching
we're great healthy tips and snacks and
ideas be sure to subscribe to my channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen a lot of
people ask me how I managed to get
everything done on the day I like to
think it's because I'm a woman obviously
but it also has a lot to do with
caffeine I do love myself a good cup of
coffee or tea but there are definitely
more helpful ways to get in your fix
than others case in point the
Frappuccino